This is
unbelievably sad news,
especially because many people
just saw her on Tuesday night's
Golden Globes.
Many tuning in
because of the first actual award
ceremony and a couple a couple of years
and her own father
being memorialized in this hit movie.
What more can you tell us about
that night?
And what's happened?
Laura, good evening.
I was at the Golden Globes.
I was at the Beverly Hilton
Hotel in the ballroom, seated
just a few tables behind
Lisa Marie and her mother, Priscilla.
And I immediately thought to myself
when I saw her
that she just didn't look like her
usual glowing bubbly, happy self.
She looked a bit somber.
And I also just want to tell you,
a few moments ago,
we received a statement from the family
represent him
saying that they are shocked
and devastated
by the tragic death
of their beloved Lisa Marie.
And like you said,
as for a statement
that Priscilla had released
that they are profoundly grateful
for the support.
Now, this comes as a shock to so many
because just a few hours ago, Priscilla
taking to Instagram,
asking for prayers in support,
telling everyone
that her daughter
was rushed to the hospital.
We know at CNN
that paramedics
responded to a call at Lisa
Marie, his home in Calabasas, California,
for possible cardiac arrest.
No other details at this time
as to what happened.
But like you said,
it was a huge night
for the Presley family.
Because Baz Luhrmann,
like you said,
immortalizing,
memorializing Elvis, their father,
her husband, Priscilla's husband, on
screen, Austin Butler doing this
incredible portrayal
and taking to the stage
when he won his Golden Globe
with this emotional speech,
looking right at the table.
He was sitting with them that evening.
I can only imagine how devastated he is.
And we haven't
heard back from him,
but we've reached out to Austin Butler
for comment.
And at
one point, it looked like Lisa
Marie was wiping tears from her eyes.
And we know how much this movie
meant to the family.
And we know how much Lisa
Marie championed
Austin Butler
and helped him
get to know what Elvis really was like.
You heard Stephanie Elam earlier
with Anderson.
You heard Nischelle Turner
from Entertainment Tonight earlier,
who interviewed her as well on the carpet
saying that something seemed off.
And I think all of us
sort of turned to the other and said,
you know, this doesn't seem like her
usual self.
But look, like you
said, it's been a rough couple of years
losing her son, Benjamin,
to suicide in 20, 20.
She opened up about it
in an essay in July.
I want to read you a little bit
of what she said.
She said,
My heart and soul went with you.
The depth of the pain is suffocating.
And bottomless
without you every moment of every day.
That is just she loved her son so much.
And like she writes, my heart
and soul went with you.
Now, we don't know what led to her
death today,
but we know it's
been a profoundly difficult time.
She is survived by three of her
other children,
Riley Keough being one of them
who is an actress.
We still have not yet heard from them,
but this is all just happened
just moments ago.
Again, we just saw her
at the Golden Globes.
It's been a big couple of months
for the family with Austin Butler
and all the rave reviews
for Baz Luhrmann's Elvis.
And this was you know,
we were about to
you're about to have Oscar nominations.
This movie is definitely, in my opinion,
going to be nominated
also and going to be nominated
know the Oscars are in March.
And this would have been a huge moment
for the family to be there together.
And now this sadness, another tragedy
that the Presley family
is so used to facing tragedy and grief
in such a public way.
Chloe, thank you.
And again, a mother
with surviving children as well.
What a devastating blow to this family.
I want to bring in Sharon Waxman, editor
in chief of The Wrap.
Sharon, so many people remember and know
and are familiar with Lisa Marie Presley
across multiple generations.
You have those who remembered
when she was the young apple
and apple of the eye
and twinkle in the
I have an Elvis Presley
and a young Priscilla.
People recall from generations
of my own included
when she was married to Michael Jackson.
Another actor, Nicholas Cage, as well.
I mean, the idea of many people
in different generations
knowing her
and then learning about her,
even in her really open way
of talking
about the grief that she experienced
and 20, 20 at the loss of her son's life.
She has been in the public eye
and here we are
learning that she has died.
What is the reaction that you
were hearing
Well, I think people are
really shocked in Hollywood
and we're just seeing an outpouring
of exactly that.
First of all,
there were people who, of course,
just saw her this one of the new new laid
back in-person
events at the Golden Globes Awards.
Seasons have just been so muted
in the past few years.
And so this year,
Elvis is one of the movies
that's really celebratory and brings
to light to going back to the movies.
And it was interesting,
in fact, that the movie was backed
by the family that they were supporting,
was learning
the director,
that they watched the film
all together with them
for the first time
ahead of the movie's release, of course.
So it's really shock.
I think that you're going to be hearing
already that story
on the side that reflects
all across entertainment
And Sharon, I mean,
she was just nine years old herself
when her father, Elvis, died.
And in many respects, it seemed as though
she considered herself
a bit of a caretaker of his legacy.
Is that right?
Yeah, I think so.
And Priscilla,
her mother, of course, as well,
I remember talking to Lisa Marie's
daughter, Riley, at the Cannes
Film Festival this year.
Riley is followed
in the family footsteps
in going into entertainment.
She's an actress,
and she directed a film
for the first time that was at the Cannes
Film Festival.
And it's just really striking
when you meet the family
there's such a strong physical book
that was passed down.
Elvis to Lisa Marie Riley has it.
Her brother had it as well.
So it's almost like,
you know,
you feel like you're
touching a little bit of history
when you meet the family.
And she describes
how they all watched the movie together.
And there was this
real sense of excitement.
Elvis, I mean, when
Sharon, thank you.
I want to bring in
CNN contributor as well,
Nischelle Turner.
Nischelle, we know that you are driving.
Thank you for being a part
of our breaking news coverage.
We really want to hear from you
because, of course,
not only you're a phenomenal
entertainment reporter,
but also you had a chance
to actually speak with her
at the Golden Globes to observe her.
Now, again,
we have no idea
if there is any connection whatsoever
to either how she appeared, her behavior,
how she felt in any way
on the night of the Golden Globes.
But it is our last ability
to see how she was in the public eye
this past Tuesday.
Tell me,
what was your impression upon
hearing the news today?
Yeah, I'm
glad that you make that clear
because we don't know.
We don't know the cause of death.
We don't know any of that right now
except for
she did
go to the hospital today
under possible cardiac arrest.
And now we have subsequently known
that she has passed away.
But when we did speak with her on Sunday,
my my co-host, Kevin Frazier, and I
she definitely did not seem at 100%.
She seemed subdued.
She did not seem at full strength.
I had just spoken with her
a couple of months earlier
at a footprint ceremony in Hollywood
for her father, for the movie,
for Austin Butler.
And I can tell you,
it was night and day difference
of how she was. She was very upbeat.
She was very bubbly.
She was very outgoing, joking.
She's funny, she's glib,
all of those things.
She did not seem that way on Sunday,
but she was happy to be there
to support the movie that
the whole family was behind
about her father's legacy.
To support Austin Butler, who she did
care for a great deal
and was so happy with his portrayal of
of her father to support Baz Luhrmann,
who was also was
the director, was also nominated
for a Golden Globe.
So it was going to be a celebratory night
for them.
They had also just
celebrated her father's birthday
a couple of days before.
So she talked about that as well
and about how special of a night
it would be
because they were celebrating her
father's birthday,
celebrating the success of the film.
And the actress portrayal of her father.
But she did not seem to be
her her normal self.